let's bring you some breaking news now
authorities in Kiev say at least three
people have been killed by Russian
shelling in the Ukrainian capital on
Wednesday strikes across Ukraine have
left the city of leviv without power
neighboring Moldova says half of the
country doesn't have electricity after
the Russian strikes in Ukraine
I speak to Rory challenge who joins us
on the phone line from Kiev so quite an
escalating situation in terms of the
results or effects of strikes
yes I mean I'm just going to describe to
you the scene that I'm looking at at the
moment we we've been on the road all day
driving from the Viv in the west to Kiev
uh the capital city we've just arrived
in Kiev now pretty much every building
is dark at the moment it's a gloomy
wintry afternoon and uh on the streets
the only lights really are the likes of
the cars headlights and tail lights most
buildings are dark there are no street
lights operating the only lights on in
the buildings belong to the buildings
that are lucky enough to have diesel
generators as backup it's the result of
you know this devastating new wave of
Russian missile strike strikes on
infrastructure targets right across the
country you you mentioned the Dettol so
far then three civilians dead in the
Kiev region that's after a newborn baby
was killed earlier in the day in a
strike on a zaparusia maternity unit
um but here's the roll call of places
where there is partial or no electricity
at the moment there's no electricity in
Kiev car Kev to nipro Lev Curry
rivneye Odessa sue me poltaba myrnocrats
uh malnitsky and jitimir you can see
that this is you know affecting cities
right across the country and as you
mentioned even Moldova next door
affected too there's no running water in
Kiev at the moment and Ukraine's power
Network operator says that it expects
blackouts to be much of the country for
up to the next 24 hours now these
strikes they're basically the latest in
in repeated hits on Ukrainian
infrastructure it began around October
the 10th that has severely depleted the
country's energy Supply earlier today
the EU Parliament voted to declare
Russia a state sponsor of terrorism and
ukrainians are pointing to the targeting
of Civilian infrastructure as indicative
of exact do that they say that this is a
war crime now I'm afraid that
International laws on warfare aren't so
clear-cut when the electricity grid is
also being used by the military but if
Russia is thinking that it can break the
will of either Ukraine's military or its
civilian population with these strikes
at the moment there is no evidence that
it's having any such effect
all right thanks so much Rory challenge